in the digital battlefield of 2024 where
cyber threats Loom larger than ever the
Arsenal new equip can be differenced
between a victim and a Victor welcome to
the tutorial hacking tools you need to
learn in 2024 last year alone the cyber
crime landscape witnessed a staggering
300% increase in cyber attacks globally
inflicting damages surpassing $6
trillion that's more than the GDP of
Japan the world's third largest economy
from the solar wind hack impacting
18,000 organizations to the Colonial
pipeline r ofare attack disrupting fuel
supplies these incidents are stock
reminders of our
vulnerabilities but within this chaos
lies opportunity the demand for skilled
cyber Security Professionals has skyro
with over 3.5 million unfulfilled cyber
security jobs globally and the first
step to joining this front line is the
mastering the tools of the trade today
we are not just going to list tools
we're diving into the cruxs of modern
hacking tools from Network analyzers
like wire shock to penetration testing
powerhouses like metas sploit we will
explore how these tools evolve in
response to the sophisticated threats of
our time imagine being able to identify
a vulnerability before the attackers do
or uncovering a critical data breach
saving Millions these aren't just
scenarios they real outcomes achieved by
experts using these tools and before
commencing just a quick info for you if
you are an aspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
lears postgraduate programm in cyber
security from mit2 University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice through this course
you will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen others the course is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and requires just a
bachelor's degree with a 50% of average
and you require no prior programming
experience and one plusus year of work
experience is preferred if you're
passionate about making your career in
this field you can check out the link in
the pin comment and description box
below so without any further Ado let's
get started with the evolving cyber
security landscape as we step into 2024
the cyber security landscape continues
to evolve at an unprecedented Pace what
does this mean for professionals and
Enthusiast alike in the field of cyber
security let's dive in in recent years
we have witnessed a significant
transformation in the types of cyber
threats from sophisticated ransomware
attacks crippling major infrastructure
to AI driven fishing schemes the
complexity and scale of attacks are
escalating one of the key drivers of
this change is the ever expanding
digital footprint of businesses and
individuals with more devices connected
to the internet than ever before the
attack surface for cyber threats has
broadened making cyber security a
critical concern another critical aspect
is the advancement in technology itself
the emergence of Technologies like
artificial intelligence machine learning
and Quantum Computing has given both
Defenders and attackers new tools this
arms race between cyber Security
Professionals and cyber criminals is
constantly reshaping the battlefield
amidst these challenges there's a silver
line the field of cyber security is
innovating rapidly Cutting Edge hacking
tools are being developed not just to
counteract these threats bu but to stay
several steps ahead we will explore the
top hacking tools of 2024 these tools
are not just a response to the evolving
threat but are shaping the future of
cyber security so let's start with
number one that is metas framework metas
sploit developed by rapid 7 is a robust
platform for developing testing and
executing exploits it includes an
extensive database of ready to use
exploits and allows for crafting of
custom payloads features of modular
architecture enabling the creation of
custom modules and scripts it offers
interfaces ranging from command line to
GUI catering to both beginners and
advanced users it provides tools for
post exploitation activities evasion
techniques and boat net management
regularly updated with contributions
from a global community of cyber
Security Professionals and then we have
the Practical applications that is ideal
for a wide range of uses including
penetration testing security Audits and
as an educational tool for understanding
digital vulnerabilities and defenses now
moving to the next tool that is wire
shock so fire shark is the Premier tool
for Network protocol analysis crucial
for Network troubleshooting protocol
development and educational purposes it
enables users to capture and analyze
live network data or work with data
captured previously it offers a
userfriendly three pain packet browser
for viewing Network traffic in real time
wire shocks capabilities include
detailed inspection of hundreds of
protocols live capture and offline
analysis it is suitable for various
levels of of expertise from Network
professionals to no Isis it provides a
comprehensive set of tools like viip
analysis which are invaluable for
diagnosing network issues and
understanding complex Network Behavior
it is widely used in cyber security for
detecting Network andom leas intrusion
detection and network forensic analysis
its ability to analyze data from
different sources makes it a universal
tool for Network Diagnostic and cyber
security research now moving to the next
that is nmap Network mapper so nmap is
renowned for its Effectiveness in
network discovery and security auditing
it excels in scanning networks to
identify devices and services making it
indispensable for cyber security
professional it offers a variety of
scanning options including host
Discovery Port scanning and version
detection nmap's ability to adapt its
scanning technique based on network
conditions and configurations make it a
powerful and flexible tool and it
features a a scripting engine nmap
scripting engine nsse that allows users
to write custom scripts for a wide range
of network task this makes nmap not just
a scanning tool but a robust network
analysis framework and it is widely
adopted by Network administrators
security Auditors and penetration
testers and map benefits from a strong
Community with regular updates and vast
library of scripts contributed by users
around the world now moving to the next
that is BB suit
so BB suit offers a full range of tools
for comprehensive web application
security testing it's known for its
capability to intercept inspect and
modify Network traffic making it
indispensable for analyzing and securing
web
applications and it includes both manual
and automated scanning options its
userfriendly interface allows for
interactive testing and detailed
analysis while the automated scanner
efficiently identifies vulnerabilities
and it features an array of tools like a
repeater for manual request modification
an intruder for automated attack
simulations and a decoder for data
analysis this makes it versatile for
different types of security assessments
and it is available in both a free
community version and a paid
professional version catering to a wide
range of users from hobbist to
Professional Security analyst the
professional version offers Advanced
features for more in-depth analysis and
then comes to the next tool that is air
crack NG so air crack NG is a suit of
software tool specifically designed for
auditing and securing Wi-Fi networks
it's recognized for its Effectiveness in
testing network security monitoring
Wi-Fi traffic and cracking encryption
key the toolkit includes functionalities
for monitoring packet capture attacking
that is fake access points
deauthorization deauthentication testing
and other network analysis task although
it is command line based aircrack NJ is
known for its straightforward interface
face making it accessible for both
beginners and experts it's compatible
with various operating systems and
wireless adapters and it's primarily
used for network security assessments
aircrack NG is a goto tool for ethical
hackers and cyber Security Professionals
for diagnosing and strengthening Wi-Fi
security protocols now moving to the
next that is six Jan the
Ripper Jon the Ripper is renowned for
its efficiency in password cracking
originally designed for Unique Systems
it supports multiple platforms and is a
goto tool for cracking complex passwords
it is capable of handling a wide array
of hash types it offers various attack
modes like dictionary root force and
hybrid attacks making it highly
adaptable for different cracking
scenarios and it is known for its
customizable nature allowing users to
tailor attacks as per their requirements
it benefits from a strong Community
providing frequent updates and
additional functionality through plugins
and Beyond password recover Discovery
Jon theer is an essential tool for
Security Professionals to conduct
password strength Audits and enforce
robust password policies in
organizational networks now moving to
the next that is kalii
Linux so Kali Linux is not just a tool
but a complete distribution packed with
over 600 pre-installed penetration
testing programs it's specifically
tailored for ethical hacking and cyber
security task so Ki offers a highly
customizable environment to fit various
cyber security needs it supports a wide
range of wireless devices and can be
tailored for specific task like Wireless
attacks web application assessment or
digital forensics actively maintained
and developed by offensive security the
platform benefits from the contributions
of a vast Community ensuring it remains
up to date with the latest cyber
security Trends and tools and it is
widely used for cyber security training
penetration testing and forensic
analysis Kali Linux also serves as a
learn learning platform for those new to
cyber security offering tools and
resources for users at all levels now
moving to the eth tool that is Zed
attack proxy so Zed attack proxy is an
open- Source tool primarily used for
finding vulnerabilities in web
applications It is Well regarded for its
Effectiveness in automated and manual
security testing and it offers a range
of functionalities including automated
scanners spidering and ax scrolling its
ability to intercept and modify HTTP
request and responses allows for
thorough testing of web apps and zap
provides a userfriendly
interface zap provides a userfriendly
interface suitable for those new to
application security as well as advanced
options for experienced testers it
supports a wide range of scripts and
addons making it highly customizable and
as the part of the project Z benefits
from a Vibrant Community receiving
regular updates and improvements it is a
tool of choice for both learning
learning and professional application
security testing now moving to the ninth
tool that is hashcat hashcat is
recognized as the world's fastest and
most advanced password security and
Recovery utility it's specifically
designed for recovering lost or
forgotten passwords offering
unparalleled efficiency and speed it
supports a vast area of HH types and
encryption algorithms its flexibility
makes it suitable for various scenarios
from simple password recovery to complex
crypto graphic analysis and it features
multiple attack modes including Brute
Force dictionary and hybrid attacks this
versatility enables hashcat to adapt to
virtually any password cracking
requirement making it a goto solution
for Security Professionals despite its
Advanced capabilities hashcat is
accessible to users of varing skill
levels it benefits from a strong
Community backing ensuring regular
updates and a rich source of shared
knowledge and strategies and the next on
the list is gidra so gidra developed by
the National Security Agency is a
powerful suit of software reverse
engineering tools it's designed for
analyzing malicious Cod and Mal
enhancing cyber security defenses and it
offers a broad range of features for
disassembly assembly decompilation
graphing and scripting these tools
assist in understanding complex software
and detecting potential vulnerabilities
as an open source tool getra benefits
from Community contributions which
constantly enrich its capabilities it
openness allows for widespread use and
adaption in various security context and
it is widely used for malware analysis
vulnerability research and understanding
proprietary software g r is also an
excellent educational tool for those
looking to delve into the entry cases of
reverse engineering and there you have
it folks we hope you enjoyed this
insightful tutorial and this was the
last tool on our list so if you like
this session then like share and
subscribe if you have any questions
then you can drop them in the comment
section below thanks for watching and
stay tuned for more from Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security
AI machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to to watch
similar videos to ner up and get
certified click
here